my name is Jon Hamm and I'm David
Tennant and we're going to be doing the
wired autocomplete interview in scottish
i will be playing Vanna White and I was
laying Carol smiley that's right British
version - Vanna White
nobody gets that Walt Jon Hamm what Jon
Hamm is what is Jon Hamm drama teacher
what is Jon Hamm drama teacher I was a
drama teacher that's what they're
getting at and I also had a drama
teacher
yeah our teachers name was Wayne Solomon
and when I was a drama teacher it was in
1985 at John burrows high school there
you go that's a pretty key those are
those are answers the question was
asking yeah what happened to jon Hamm's
voice well that's a very interesting
story
no I didn't know that I had surgery on
my vocal cords in 2013 yes I did I had a
polyp on my vocal cord that had to be
removed it was removed and that's what
is Jon Hamm well interesting enough
tomorrow's never it is and I'll be 48
years old he's various to sing songs
we're not children a shot up what high
school did Jon Hamm get go to it yeah
thank you go well cosmic uh Jon
Burroughs night school yeah
st. Louis Missouri from 1983 to 1989 and
then you went back and taught that and
then oh my buckets out there and if I
yeah pretty cool has been kill oh and I
I named a theater after my theater
teacher JJ that's nice that's good
you are a nice guy make me sick what TV
show was John damn and it's a small
world I think it must be yeah
doctor the unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt
aggregate 30 rock Barry Allen I live all
so good mmm all right okay is David
Tennant is David Tennant is David
Tennant Scottish Scottish ish Scotty is
David Tennant related to Charlie yes I
mean obviously we're brothers who thinks
that cuz you kind of look alike do we
yeah Charlie Sheen I mean you're like
two and a half Charlie David Tennant
again why would anyone ask that I'm not
vegan leave us but I'm more vegetarian
than I used to be I think we all are at
your head last night what yoky yeah
crazy knows delicious is David Tennant
left-handed that off with my left you do
but I don't have to principally I'm on
this high all righty
something David Tennant why Dave oh how
old David town doesn't a question mark
this is bad grammatically how old and
they'll turn white as old as Jon Hamm
well you wanna know to tell me what I'm
I'm just a month behind you every team
hello old David Tennant how old Jon Hamm
little boy I don't like you this at all
I'm gonna peel as well use up your Kofi
how did John how did John Hamm and Paul
Rudd meet a good friend of Mines older
brother was his roommate in college and
so he came back from college for
Thanksgiving or something like that and
we all played through the particular
okay it's before the internet and things
like Google so you had to play board
games
how tall is Jon Hamm 6-1 6-2 is Warner
okay Jonah that's what I did I think
what is that an extra half-inch in
quarter uh where did John Hamm first
work my first job was as a dishwasher at
Spiros restaurant in seeing those are
the dishes in a Greek restaurant harder
to clean than the dishes of another
where is Jon Hamm in Game of Thrones
good question ah finally a question I'd
like to know the answer to where is John
Hammond where's David Tennant in Game of
Thrones excellently they hired everybody
in Europe for that show I knew only
English actor though innit we're gonna
Dingling glitch but I mean foam England
I would have liked to the game throws a
good route I could have ridden that
dragon can John him write a dragon
Verity show up and I see oh let's find
out no David this is more exciting for
me David Tennant does lieutenant reply
there man now I wanna take this one Wow
come buddy does you know why Time Lords
there all the time in the hands yeah
you know what I will do though and this
is a good fan mail tip I bet you do the
same thing yeah if there's not a
self-addressed and so there are guys
it's over yeah I can't be bothered
yeah yeah does lieutenant speak French
oui yasuno mids David Tennant speak
French carry the Olympic torch only in
Doctor Who which of course is the real
reality wait but you did it there was a
there was a we we did the 2012 Olympics
before we did the 2012 Olympics
why did David Tennant change his name
Oh actors union this is all I yeah it's
online I'm David John McDonald from
Paisley anymore two two actors unions on
different sides of the planet made me
change my name twice I'm hired to meet
David Tennant oh that's not that's it
how do me David Ken how to meet a
lieutenant you just walk up
yeah and then always this time you have
to find me though you'll definitely find
him I keep my thing so I will make it
difficult for you don't call him Tom
Baker though I don't like that is jon
Hamm's John ham related to me a ham no
it is time ham British absolutely not
it's Jon Hamm single it's don't have a
feminist sure is Johnny a baseball fan
yes look at that great come on come on
well hammering through them what is
David Tennant doing know I'm sitting
you're answering these questions but I'm
going fastest we're running out of time
what what is David Tennant in Good Omens
I was on playing video of what is David
Tennant's nationality Scottish man today
and what is the lieutenant's phone
number over here that's a little
personal yeah that's my mom nine one
okay what is David Tennant Hamlet I
don't know who's David Tennant I would
like to ask the Internet to please use
better grandma's wellies check your
syntax check your graph entering things
into the Google search box but we had a
lovely time not sure good thank you
cheers Internet